um
this time the guy is going to come in
right the guy comes in like this right
okay this time he's going to come in
and push the car shoulder okay
so you were here this time you step
in you push the car
the other side
so it could be like boom
okay we're just doing the push part
but you have to keep in mind it could
easily go
okay you guys understand
so the guy is going to push right
and they're going to do the same foot
maneuver
not well ahead of him because he's not
going to do that
i have to ride in him
too early
all right if i am late then my base
is affected
if i'm early his base is not okay
but if i do it right time
my base is not affected you see that
little
residual intention okay that's what you
want
today i'm i'm manipulating
too early he's not
right where he's gonna push you
so you have your angle of deviation
and you want it redundant with the angle
of deflection
but you can't deflect so that you don't
have that residual intention on this
part
let it come to your body you see
see how he is coming in
in
okay try it
um
yeah you don't want either or okay
you don't want residual intention
you don't want or
arm control okay you use one to give you
the other
see the difference okay
see that little extra hop he's taking
i want that
so you see what's happening is you're
all fine
pushing when you like he's not here okay
and you're all fine pushing
but the second you start aiming down
then you stop pushing
okay you can't be a coward you cannot be
a coward to train aikido
all right you cannot worry about your
face so much
you know how many times my nose has been
broken so
you can't come in here do that
what was your attack right
right let's do that one with this other
cowardice one
not the same thing he's gonna punch me
when i come back
oh right because i went again
so make sure you you come in you can go
slow but you have to keep coming in
when he does the technique boom
you keep coming in you can't control the
speed if you want
but you cannot change the physics do not
change the attack
can you push your shoulder in his head
all right let's work on this
the guy's coming in and i have
this right watch what his body does
all i'm going to do is keep his arm
going on that circle you guys can
visualize
that's all i'm doing but i just had my
face
one
okay so i get the residuals
it's kind of like poke hole isn't it
hey
you